Are we debugging code here or are we building coding standards?
Are we building coding standards or debugging code?
>> I dunno. It seems to me that I'm being blamed on a lot of things,
that just you know, depending on the fact of having a standard or not but
it's [INAUDIBLE].
>> Research says building standards significantly reduces the number of
errors in software.
And so, we should.
Make a note that there are no standards existing in this group, and
that they ought to be done.
Here's some suggestions, but
that's a bigger problem than what we're addressing here.
>> [COUGH] While you're starting it, let's continue it Doctor Vaughn.
>> At this point we just you know,
there's just brackets to c lose catch statement And
then the method, and then the classes, and then that's it, the codings.
>> What is the exit status if everything runs correctly?
>> Oh, it just says it's fine.
>> Shouldn't we be setting an exit status of zero.
>> I think that's probably by default or something.
>> Is it? I don't know, I'm not so sure.
>> I don't know I thought it was by default.
That's what told me.
>> Yeah, but- [CROSSTALK]. >> That was for in our job.
So, you have to be. [LAUGH].
>> Well, while we're [COUGH] mention printing to a log.
Shouldn't we, for the, when we're printing the characters in the while loop.
Shouldn't that, isn't that debug information.
Does the user even need to see that?
They just really need to see the count, right?
Shall we be worried about what's being print to kind of the logger and
then what's printed to standard out?
>> Well, I see that you're kind of changing the specs on me but yeah.
If there has to be a logger then yeah the model will have to change.
>> Well, it says right here, the purpose.
Count the number of blanks in a sentence.
>> Right, I know. >> It doesn't say a purpose.
Write out all of the things.
>> Hm. >> You know, as you're going along.
>> So is the comment wrong or the spec wrong?
>> Well, it's a, that's an excellent question.
I would say that the I believed what I read there.
But I could be incorrect.
>> Yeah, that's the spec I got.
>> Since this is a program without a specification.
I think he just invented it, you know, just.
[CROSSTALK] So he said I need to do this.
He said, okay I can do that.
[CROSSTALK] I can copy code from various places and hack this thing together.
>> This way it was nice for the users to see what [INAUDIBLE] but
it doesn't have to be the case.
>> I don't know what kind of users you've been around.
>> Oh, you know, users that can put a period at the end of the sentence.
[CROSSTALK].
We did and Dr. Bug, anything else for this?
>> That's sound perfectly good.